la pénurie de logements compris que la
vie à de nombreux résidents de los
angeles
au point que certains d'entre eux
décident d'habiter dans de petites
capsules l'espace serait à peine trois
mètres carrés mais il al'avantage de
coûter un peu moins de 1000 $ par mois
et ce prix inclut l'accès au studio
d'enregistrement
une salle de danse et à une cuisine
commune en plus de la lessive et du
ménage gratuit au total la résidence
compte une centaine de capsules et pas
partie d'un complexe de quatre maisons
qui sont majoritairement occupés par des
artistes
vu le peu d'intimité et les hommes et
les femmes doivent dormir séparément et
les relations sexuelles sont
formellement interdites
[Musique]